[Music]
hello and welcome to our session deploy
your next application to google
kubernetes engine I'm William Dennis a
product manager on Google kubernetes
engine and later I'll be joined by
Marshall and CAD from fair in today's
session we're going to be covering three
broad topics first we're going to talk
about why you might want to use
communities in the first place and some
of the benefits you can expect to
realize if you do then I'm going to do a
demo on deploying an app into google
kubernetes engine and finally we're
going to talk a little bit about how to
introduce Kuban at ease into your
enterprise alright so why should you use
communities as your application platform
well first and foremost kubernetes is a
container platform so you inherit all
the benefits of developing with
containers these include things like
language and library flexibility so no
longer are you limited to a particular
language in your production environment
like a certain version of Java or a
certain version of Ruby and no longer do
you have to put up with some
three-year-old Lisa
release of a library that for some
reason is still shipping in your Linux
distribution with containers the
developer is in control of what they
want to run and exactly how they want to
configure it
you also get isolated dependencies so
you can run multiple containers on a
single machine without them interfering
with each other and production and
development uniformity this is one of my
favorite features so your production
environment looks very very close to
your development environment and in fact
if you have a bug in production you can
typically download that container run it
on your developer machine attached to
say the staging endpoints and actually
debug the exact code that was running in
production not only that but you also
get uniformity between the developers on
your team so gone are the days where you
have to spend like a whole day
conferring some development machine with
all the various tools and things that
you need just install docker and you can
immediately be building these containers
you can even have someone on the team
using a Windows machine someone using a
Linux machine someone using Mac all
developing and deploying Linux
containers or whatever operating system
that you wanted to use
and you get all this with really minimal
overhead and complete resource isolation
so in the past you might have used
virtual machines to get some of these
benefits by comparison containers a very
lightweight both in the execution and
the low overhead of the actual like an
image size so back to kubernetes
communities is then a container platform
that manages those containers for you it
does things like handling how to
schedule and launch the containers on
the machines he'll do things like reboot
any containers that crash you can even
run continually monitor them with health
checks so that it won't rat traffic to
something that's hung or a replica of
your application that say is missing its
connection to the database it performs a
lot of operations like this all with the
goal of keeping your application up and
running without too much help from you
so kubernetes is a workload level
abstraction and what I mean by that is
you describe your workload and and it
basically has the job of running out for
you so for example let's say you have a
server that you want to run in a
distributed way or you have a database
that has a disk attached that needs to
follow it around well maybe you want to
have a logging utility that runs on
every single node or maybe you have a
movie that you want to write render one
frame at a time using the cheapest
possible computer these are all
different workloads and these are all
things that you can just represent in
communities terms and it can handle for
you and I believe that kubernetes sits
at the right level of abstraction it's
not super low level in the sense that
you're not having to deal with
individual machines anymore but it's not
too high level in in the sense that it
doesn't need a feel with what you're
trying to do with your application it
kind of sits very cleanly in the middle
and for me this contrasts to a
traditional pass which kind of like
merges into the application layer by
imposing a lot of restrictions on you
and also even occasionally like even
modifying how the code actually runs
with kubernetes these layers between the
infrastructure the application platform
in the application itself are very very
clean and I think that's important
because when you're choosing
the application platform you want to use
and when you're looking at abstraction
layers you want to prioritize making
hard tasks possible over making simple
tasks easier so kubernetes instead of
focusing on the easiest type of
application to deploy which is typically
say a stateless application and making
that task easier it actually focuses on
making it possible for you to deploy a
really wide range of far more complex
deployments things like machine learning
batch tasks or a database that has state
and it can do all this while enabling a
lot of really nice cost efficiencies as
well so I mentioned before that
containers have really low overhead when
you combine that property of containers
with the power of kubernetes to manage
those containers for you you can
actually really pack a whole bunch of
containers onto machines and you can
have a bunch of machines running a
really high efficiency and you can even
do that in such a way that doesn't
compromise the availability and
reliability of your services and this
was really something I think that's
unique to kubernetes and one of the real
big value adds that kubernetes brings
over just raw containers kubernetes also
comes with a rich ecosystem and
community so let's say you want to add
like some logging or monitoring service
to your application with kubernetes you
typically have the choice you can either
get some open source and run it yourself
or you can find a vendor that can manage
and run that for you I think this is
really good because the kind of lets you
pick and choose what you want to focus
on maybe in some areas you'd rather have
someone else manage it for you but in
others maybe you actually really want to
understand how that's working and you
want to run it yourself with kubernetes
you always have both options I find with
pretty much anything that you want to
try and do and of course cubanos itself
is open source and perhaps equally
importantly it's really widely available
how wide well if you look at the
certified kubernetes program run by the
CN CF they the cloud native compute
foundation you'll see that there are
currently 32 platforms that are
certified 54 distributions and 14
installs so you really have a wide range
of choice of where you want to run that
kubernetes and of course google
kubernetes engine is a
of the certified communities program and
certainly not all communities platforms
are created equal
kubernetes engine was one of the very
earliest to go to market the earliest
managed kubernetes product and we have a
lot of really robust automation
capabilities things like cluster auto
scaling which can add compute resources
when you need them and remove them in
kind of a quiet period so you can save
some money we have things like node
order appear which can monitor various
unhealthy conditions in nodes and
automatically replace them and we have
nodal node order upgrade which allows
you to stay up to date with the latest
features and security patches without
you needing to lift a finger
together these three features and more
really help automate a lot of the
operations for you and it basically
means less 3 a.m. flowing phone calls
for you and perhaps importantly equally
importantly I think that the same team
that brings you gke actually contribute
over 40% to kubernetes itself so my
team's contributions over kind of yellow
orange line at the bottom here then you
can see that not only do we contribute
40 percent but we've actually really
sustained and and had a long-term
commitment to communities this graph
goes back nearly 5 years and what this
means for you is that if you hit some
bug in communities or you're having
difficulty with something that you just
can't figure out well I'm pretty sure
there's someone on my team who's going
to be able to help you with that problem
probably the person that actually wrote
the feature that you're using and of
course you get all this with the
benefits of Google cloud so all the
benefits that you're hearing about this
week and that you will hear about this
week such as our you know world-class
fiber network you inherit all these
benefits on Google community engine from
Google cloud I really like this network
you know with this you're basically
getting the benefits of of YouTube in a
way right like Google build this thing
out to handle YouTube and you know your
little app can can run on the exact same
fiber network and we're even
you know deploy undersea cables now so
again all the benefits of Google cloud
in communities Anjan
and speaking of scale gke can definitely
handle your scale so I think this is
really important actually that you know
when you're when you're designing in
your application that you really want to
think about scalability from the start
you know unless you're creating some
internal only like a lunch ordering app
I'm sure you want more users and you
want more scale but imagine if at that
very moment when everyone's kind of
beating down the door trying to get into
your product at that very moment of
potential success your application falls
over that's just terrible that's just
the worst thing so I believe if you
start with gke and as long as you follow
some good scalability principles you
know we can be there for you and ready
to hand of your scale and set you up for
success a great example of such a
success is Niantic when they launched a
pokemon you might have heard of this app
last year or two years ago and when they
launched they actually had the first
date traffic or the first kind of week
traffic was something in order of 50
times their original projection and ten
times their worst case projection of
traffic we're still able to handle that
and as you may know the launch was
fairly successful so another thing about
communities is it doesn't have a very
strongly opinionated development
deployment workflow so you might think
that's a burden in a sense that you do
have to actually set up your own
deployment workflow but fortunately
using something like cloud run you can
actually get a deployment workflow out
pretty quickly and the real power comes
in when you actually need to set up some
business logic for your enterprise this
might be something like a vulnerability
scanner that you want to run before
every deploy to ensure that no
vulnerabilities are getting out into the
wild or perhaps it's just some other
admission control that you just want to
check some behavior enforce something to
make sure your developers aren't doing
the wrong thing all these kind of custom
business logics are possible for you to
set up in incriminate engine with your
own custom pipeline and with that I'd
actually like to invite up Marshall and
Kat from fair who have a lot to say
about kubernetes
hey everyone my name is Marshall and I'm
cat and we're from Fair cool so if you
haven't heard of Fair before you don't
know what it is
Fair is a new car ownership model that
sounds like really marketís so what does
that actually mean if you download the
app sign up you can search for a car
that fits your needs and your budget
once you have that car you can give it
back at any time so there's no time
commitment and the entire thing is a
mobile experience
you sign and pay for the car all in the
app if you're interested you know check
it out in the App Store so I'm sure a
lot of us has gone through the
experience of buying a car and you've
probably realized that it's not really a
fun experience it's pretty outdated
it's just jointed and there's not really
Automation about it
there's haggling involved you got to get
your own financing you have to get
insurance at the end there's a ton of
physical paperwork to sign every single
part of that process can be its own
business and usually is its own business
affairs decided that we're gonna try and
abstract all that into a single
experience that's what we've done
but unfortunately that brings a lot of
legal financial and operational
complexities so kind of from the start
we said maybe a service-oriented
architecture is gonna be a good fit for
us as we try and build out a business
that literally didn't exist actually
kind of a funny story with that like two
weeks before we launched we decided
we're gonna add insurance as a product
on that and we were able to do that
because of the way that we had
structured our services but with a lot
of services comes complexity and you
need to manage that complexity somehow
and that's kind of where we chose Kate
Herrmann at ease but how do we actually
end up on communities we didn't start
there the early faire employees we had
experiences at prior companies with past
products and you know we knew them so we
started with those and it was working
but it really only solved one part of
the deployment process which is really
just or not processed but solution for
you know API servers web servers
background job kind of things it solved
those but our data scientist team they
had really subpar infrastructure they
were coming from a prior company where
their training was actually done on a
fixed set of VMs and some in office
hardware so it wasn't flexible and it
wasn't scalable the way they actually
did their training is they had you SSH
onto a box pull down their model code
run the training code and then check
back in on it later so they were
actually kind of having to coordinate
leasing all of that hardware among
themselves in order to get their their
training done so when coming to fair
they said okay we're not going to bring
all that baggage with us we're gonna try
something new and they were
experimenting with ways of expressing
their training using kind of like
directed workflows but they needed
something to actually power that system
they need some infrastructure there so
that's kind of where I came in I was
like okay you need this problem solved
let me go look around find find some
things in the solution space I was
looking for something that was
relatively simple to use and set up and
could give them kind of on-demand
capacity so what they needed to submit
their training jobs we could scale up
and when they didn't have anything to
train we could scale down so we weren't
paying cost on that hardware pretty
quickly we found kubernetes and that was
really back in the like kubernetes 1.1
1.2 days and took a few weeks we
integrated it with their systems and we
got it working and it was a huge success
it gave them all the flexibility that
they needed and after a few more weeks
we realized wait the workloads that
we're running here for they're their
data science training we could actually
be running all of our workloads on
kubernetes the API servers background
jobs etc so we cut everything over and
honestly our devs were actually a little
resistant because you know their their
previous pass products they were using
honestly were simpler but at the end of
the day the ability to actually have all
of our workloads boarding on a single
platform with a single set of tooling
that kind of operational simplicity
really won out and you know we started
pretty small and simple just a couple
services but have we've grown we're you
know we're not at Google but we're
running 40 some-odd various kind of
workload
and kuru neighs has always been able to
run every single one of those for us so
we've been running kubernetes for two
years what are some of the benefits
we've actually seen well workflow
customization so William actually
mentioned in his portion of the
presentation that kubernetes has really
solid primitives for expressing
different workload types and we were
actually able to leverage that to write
a lot of tooling to automate and
abstract our deployment workflow so what
does that mean well we created these
standardized build and release pipelines
that simplify how an application goes
from source to production so our
developers actually can spin up an
entirely new service and put it into
production and our platform team does
not have to be involved with a process
which is amazing for someone like me
because I don't want to spend all day
dealing with a developer and helping
them like put their app into production
right so how do we actually do this well
it actually assumes a lot of defaults
but we actually give developers the
flexibility to override some of the
defaults and our pipelines to fit their
specific needs
so what a data scientist might actually
need to deploy their app is very
different from what in a regular app
developer needs right and my point
really is that even though like our
pipeline needs have changed over time
you know in two years fare has grown a
lot kubernetes has always been
underneath very flexible and been able
to fit our needs so the next benefit we
actually got was it forced us into very
good operational patterns so we don't
have any apps that are pets or special
snowflakes and if you're not familiar
with the pets versus cattle analogy I'll
like spell it out for you very quickly a
pet is that like one box that you have
in production that you know you have to
give a lot of love and you know if it
goes down you're really screwed a cattle
is more you know the box that you know
you can terminate it and there's
probably another one that's already
running or will come back up you know
very quickly so you don't have like a
huge problem if it's down in product
right so that's the way that we actually
think of our application
we run our applications to try and be as
stateless as possible and the reason for
that is because kubernetes can terminate
your workload at any time and actually
shift it onto another node so for
example you know your node might
actually be suffering from something
critical like it might have very high
disk utilization or you know high CPU
utilization so it might actually
terminate your app and then move it on
to another node so as a result like the
way that we think about our applications
it's stateless we try and like run
multiple replicas of them and most of
our apps actually need to be resilient
to you know running multiple versions at
a time because kubernetes does rolling
deployments one other really awesome
benefit we got out of kubernetes was
standardized application visibility so
with kubernetes you can see all of your
app logs all of your app metrics they're
all in one place and on top of that you
can see like what apps are actually
deployed in the cluster so with all of
that we actually got some like really
cool hidden benefits out of kubernetes
as well
we actually migrated our entire workload
into another cloud onto gke without any
trouble so it comes to my next point and
the long list of things you're probably
like considering you know when you're
like thinking about adopting kubernetes
is like whether or not to go managed or
unmanaged we're at a Google conference
so really you know gke or unmanaged
right so we actually started on AWS
in 2016 and we actually didn't have any
managed options on AWS
eks which is Amazon's equivalent of gke
didn't come out until late 2017 so we
actually opted to run unmanaged because
that was the only choice and we've been
running it for two years and we've
learned a lot about kubernetes so we've
developed a lot of really good in-house
expertise on kubernetes but also after
two years we realized you know it's
actually a full-time job to like run
your machines it's a lot of security
patches upgrading your machines and I
know that you know for a lot of people
in ops you're kind of worried
going you want to go unmanaged because
you don't want to lose operational
control I'm just gonna say like take it
from us we've been doing this for two
years and when we migrated our workloads
to gke we didn't necessarily feel like
we were you know trading off or giving
up a lot of control and more importantly
like kubernetes is such a great
abstraction on top of cloud providers
that we transitioned and moved all of
our apps from AWS to gke and we didn't
have to make any application changes but
speaking of apps and deployments
Williams gonna come back onstage and
he's actually going to demo how to
deploy your app into kubernetes alright
so before I get started with the demo I
just wanted to quickly cover a few key
kubernetes concepts so that some of the
stuff in the demo will make sense just
if you're new to pupa notice so we'll
start with containers communities
actually wraps containers up into what's
called a pod so a pod is with the
kubernetes the smallest schedulable unit
meaning that it these containers get
deployed together so maybe you'll have
like just one container in a pod or
maybe you have multiple in the case you
have like a sidecar container that adds
like logging or monitoring or something
like that so that's a pod then we have a
concept called nodes nodes are really
just a fancy way of saying a machine
which is either a VM or bare metal and
the real workhorse in communities is a
concept called a deployment and
communities works on this kind of
operator pattern where you just you
specify how many pods you want in the
deployment so you say like I want you
know two of pod a and one of pod B and
then criminales has this operator
pattern that then seeks to drive the
actual observe state in the cluster to
be the required state that you specified
so that looks like something like this
so so we have a system and we have two
of pod a one of pod B and then if one of
those nodes were to become unhealthy and
disappear the system would very quickly
notice oh wait a minute there's only
like one of
they running now and none of pot B it's
gonna then reschedule those on to
another node at which time it will then
observe that the desired state has been
met and everything is right in the world
again so that all happens automatically
that's kind of one of the very nice
things about communities and that
operator pattern applies to various
other constructs as well lastly we have
a service and so a service is just a
group of identical pods that together
kind of provide like a logical like API
service all right and with that I'm
gonna go to the demo okay
so I was gonna do like a fairly boring
hello world app but I decided on Friday
actually to to make something a little
more interesting so I wrote a little
server in Swift and this server is
actually using this other little project
at Google called plus codes to convert a
geographical coordinate you know a plus
code anyway that's that's what the the
apps gonna do
I picked Swift because I don't think
Swift is really used a whole lot in
production yet and I kind of wanted to
emphasize one of those points oh yeah
now with containers you really get a lot
of flexibility like I love Swift but
personally I've really just not seen too
much been in production so if you do
want to use Swift in production I dare
say that GK is a good place for you to
do it alright so what is this little app
do this little app it's using a library
called Swifter I'm just gonna start like
a basic HTTP server handle one endpoint
I'm gonna pause a couple parameters
we're gonna convert a latitudinal longer
tune or corner into a plus code and then
we're gonna return that as jason well
let's just take a quick look at what
that code looks like I'm gonna build
that container real quick and since it's
actually cached it should hopefully be
fairly fast all right and let me run
that locally and so I'm gonna Ford port
8080 on my machine to port 80 in the
container there let me show you what
that looks like
all right so this is the little end
point and that's using my example data
so to prove to you that this is real let
me let me pull up some an actual
latitude and longitude to throw in there
let's look at the Moscone Center I'm
just gonna use a Wikipedia for this just
a good source of geographical
coordinates so let me grab those working
in here and then this is the plus code
for the Moscone Center so if you have
Google Maps you can type this into
Google Maps and you can find where we
are and when I actually one of the cool
things about this is you can actually
drop off the first four digits if you're
in the same region okay so anyway that's
the that's my Swift app running in a
container running locally let's get it
up onto kubernetes so on kubernetes gke
you can create a cluster just with a few
clicks I'll show you what that looks
like I just tap that create cluster
button and then we have a whole list of
templates so you can pick from so just
pick the one that matches your workload
the best so say for this demo frankly
speaking this little your first cluster
would probably be quite sufficient I can
leave all that as default click create
now since that might take a couple of
minutes to come up I'm just gonna use
this one that I created earlier which is
next demo so let's take a look at that
cluster okay and I can click the deploy
button and it's going to ask me for a
container image so let's go back to the
console and I'm gonna tag that image and
this is using a special tag for Google
container registry which is GC r dot IO
and then my project name and then my my
application name so I'm going to push
that up
and of course looks like my cash is gone
so we're gonna test how good my wide
connection is top-load a gigabyte of
data while we're waiting for it to
happen let me just show you a couple
things here so kubernetes um we show you
the the workloads and the services and
any applications you're running all in
the UI which i think is something that
maybe isn't isn't available on other
platforms yet so for example you can go
in look at the services that are running
I'll see how that's going
all right about halfway done okay so
while we're waiting for that upload let
me let me queue up some changes so after
I've deployed that one thing I'm going
to show you is also how to do an update
so the first update I'm going to do is
I'm gonna just make a very small change
in this whole service let's add like a
status field like this one so let me let
me cue that up while we're waiting
alright it looks like we are good okay
so I'll go back to that deployment that
I was creating and I'm gonna pick that
image that I just pushed to Google
container registry I can leave the
command is default because it's just
gonna pick up the come on from the
docker file I'm gonna give that a name
I'm gonna pick my cluster which is going
to be that demo cluster that was hit
deploy so this is now created a
kubernetes deployment all via the UI I
can also take a look from the command
line and see see how that deployment is
so I do this cube CTL get pods which is
basically doing the same thing but on
the command line just inspecting the
state of those pods and we can see that
already we have three containers three
pods running with that container so you
can see just how fast that is
now the next thing I'll need to do here
is expose this as a service so I'm going
to go expose I'm going to leave that as
port 80 because that's my service pick a
load balancer so we can access it from
the internet and click expose now that
action will take about 30 seconds to
complete because it's actually
provisioning at Google any cast IP or
one of various points of presence around
the world so to save time there i've
actually prepared that one earlier so
we'll go to the services tab here and we
can see this service that i created
earlier and just take a look at that and
so that is now the same application but
running in google kubernetes engine let
me pick another coordinate to try out
just saying I'm not faking it let's look
at say the Golden Gate Bridge user we
appear again grab that glad you no
longer feel cornered okay and I said I
would also demonstrate an update so
let's go back to the console will build
the container again this time tag is
version two fortunately this one should
be quick to upload sorry I need actually
build that
okay go to first
and while we're waiting for that let me
go back into our deployment view here
and I'll show you how to update so I can
just go into the deployment I created
and I can use this update action here
rolling update and I'll specify that
same image tag that I just created and I
can also customize just how quickly I
want this thing to roll out so by
default when kubernetes does a rolling
update it will one by one replace the
pods in in the deployment and we'll do
it in such a way that there's no
downtime if I really want that to go out
quickly I can kind of just say you know
what I just want everything to go out of
once so we can try that here okay so
that now that container is built let me
push it up and then I'll hit the Update
button alright one of the nice thing
about kubernetes is even if I click
cleats that update button before the
container was ready you will actually
handle that condition so you would
actually try and pull that image it
would notice that it wasn't present and
it would try again a few seconds later
that's all part of that operated pattern
I was saying where kubernetes is driving
the desired state towards sorry it's
driving the observe state towards your
desired state alright and if I go back
in here I should now see we have a new
version of the application running just
a few seconds ago image name okay that
would be the reason okay and looking at
the UI view here we see that revision 3
of my deployment isn't currently in the
container creating state so very shortly
that will be available for use I can
inspect the same thing on the console
and it looks like it might actually be
running ok so let's get back to our
example refresh that and you see we have
that status
okay so that's how to deploy and then
update your application in google cubed
engine I'm gonna show one more thing
real quick and that is how to set up a
cloud build continuous integration
pipeline so let's get a cloud build and
let's also open up the source repository
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
push my application up to the git
repository in the cloud and I'm then
going to use a continuous integration
process to build that container so first
thing I'll create the git repo and I'll
call that plus code go back to the app
I'm going to make one more change just
so we can we can observe that change
let's say the status is now awesome and
thank you for laughing all right let's
commit that
well actually before I push let me
create a build trigger so now I'm going
to cloud build into the triggers and I'm
gonna add a trigger so that any time
code is pushed to that repository I just
created
it's going to build the image the
container image in that repository so I
can actually leave this all all is the
default and it'll actually build my talk
the image for me okay so now let me push
that up and if we go to the history here
we'll see that a bill has just kicked
off and again this is going to take a
minute
but one nice thing is I already know
what the image name is so I can grab
that and I can do the rolling update
right now even before it's ready so I'm
just putting in the image name here from
cloudbuilt and in this case I'm gonna
say I want to max about unavailable of
zero so I don't want communities to take
down any containers until the new one is
ready I will do a surge of three though
because I think there's enough capacity
to handle that all right so two things
are happening here kubernetes is
actually waiting for that container to
appear and we're waiting for that
container to finish building looks like
it is underway all right well I think
we've waited enough for me to upload
things so if you really want you can
grab that IP and check it out later and
you should see my deployment from cloud
built with that I'll go back to the
slides please
all right so one final word about Plus
codes if you thought that was
interesting technology take a look at
plus doc codes this is a little project
that a bunch of Google's work on in
their 20% time I think it's pretty cool
there's also a video to check out and
I'll be putting the code that are used
in the demo online later as well that
will be the link at the bottom there
where I'll upload it it's not actually
available quite yet but I'll make sure
that's up by the end of the week okay so
what are the next steps so now that
we've got our application deployed into
kubernetes
by the UI there's certainly a lot of
things that you might want to do before
you're ready to hit the you know go to
prod button on that the first one to
consider would be readiness aliveness
checks so these are probes that you can
configure in kubernetes where kuben is
continuously probes your container to
ensure that it's actually still running
and Regis serve traffic then I think
you'll want to look at requests and
limits this is specifying the resources
that your your container will need
requests relate to how much resources
get reserved when your container is
scheduled and limits is the maximum of
those resources that your container can
use so when your limits are greater than
your requests it means that your
container can actually use any
unutilized resources on that note
thirdly I'd recommend looking at
configuration is code so you saw me just
deploying things and updating things via
the UI which is a really great way to
get started and learn kubernetes but
eventually you want to get that
configuration you want to download it
into your version control and treat it
just like source code so have any
configuration changes go through code
review and and any kind of security
process you have with your source code
and through that you'll also gain the
ability to rollback so if you released a
version by changing the configuration
through get you then realize it was a
mistake where you can just do a git
revert and your configuration would
revert and criminals will update finally
I would recommend looking at auto
scaling so gke in particular has a
really good auto scaling technology I
actually demoed one last year at next
and I've put the link up here for you if
you're interested to see it you can
actually set up a requests per second
based pod auto scholar which is really
kind of cool stuff basically lets you
say you know for every 100 simultaneous
requests per second that I'm getting I
won't have like one pod backing that you
know so if you get a thousand I want ten
pods that is something that you can just
basically state in like three lines of
configuration and google kubernetes
engine will make that happen for you all
right so with that I'd like to invite
Kat and Marshall back up on stage where
we're going to have a bit of a
conversation about rolling out
kubernetes to your enterprise canada
Marshall
nice so one thing we realized as we were
preparing for this talk is your
experience with Cuban aids is kind of I
guess really similar to some other
customers I was spoken to particularly
the way that you actually deploy
communities into your organization so it
might be interesting to just have the
audience hear from you sort of how you
introduce the Cuban A's to your org yeah
so in terms of like introducing
kubernetes into you know your
organization and how quickly you should
do it I would say it very slowly like
glacially slowly especially if you have
a lot of workloads that already in
production that aren't on kubernetes for
us we had the benefit of being able to
start on kubernetes but I think for most
companies you know kubernetes is a huge
thing to like you know bite into I guess
and so probably the best thing to do is
to you know cut over non-critical maybe
new apps into your kubernetes cluster
and started like developing in-house
expertise before you know you go whole
hog into it yeah also we had basically a
year to develop in private and more
importantly fail a lot in private so
that that was sort of why we were able
to start with it but as Kat said start
slowly with kind of non-critical things
because there's it's easy to make
mistakes like that demo showed where you
know you you roll out your change and
you've got the image wrong and you
didn't set any safety and something your
application is entirely down and so
readiness checks for that kind of crews
to learn like well live what average
level of communities noise just that
doesn't evolve so like you know for
example does the typical application
developer need to know about services
and deployments and yamo files and
things like that in their daily job yeah
I think for us most developers are kind
of at an observability point of their
knowledge they still are doing some
configuration at sort of the deployment
and service level but it's pretty
standardized in terms of like that's all
they need to know there
a whole bunch of other abstractions that
curviness provides that they don't
really need to so I think we have some
power users obviously who are doing you
know I think our data science team
honestly is on the the further side of
that power user side and they're doing a
lot of interesting stuff and they really
are in the weeds but for most people
it's just like let the pipeline take
care of it and then use you know keep
TTL to see you know what does that
actually look like what's your state
your your deployments yeah I remember
when you said that like I really kind of
like that that setup where if I'm a
developer I can kind of not use any of
the committee's if I don't if I don't
want to and just like just focus on my
container or if I really need to
understand how things are working out of
the hood as well and I think that kind
of to me at least contrast this to a
path where you sort of can't get access
to that lower layout right and so we
talked about failure what tips do you
have for making making your workloads or
is more resilient
just we actually set anti affinity
policies so that basically means telling
kubernetes hey I actually want to
schedule you know pods of one deployment
on two different nodes this is actually
one of those moments where it's like yes
you should actually fail privately spend
some time like really learning
kubernetes because this is something
that we weren't really aware of and we
actually you know it became like a war
story in the sense that oops we screwed
this up
we were actually rolling over a cluster
bringing in new machines and this
happens very rarely but we had all of
the pods of one deployment on one
machine and when that machine was
trained and it was taken down we
accidentally took down that entire
deployment and service so basically with
kubernetes if you don't actually specify
how you want your pods kind of spread
out you know you could be very unlucky
and have them all land on one so that's
kind of it I mean yeah it'll just do a
best guess and try and fit where it can
which is great in terms of you know
filling up your VMs as best as possible
but unless you give it those hints it's
like I'll put them all on one place and
so since you set up the anti infinity
how's it working anti affinity
and I'm kind of interested in your
journey you know particularly the sense
that you started unmanaged did you want
to elaborate any more about that yeah
sure I mean obviously as as Kat said we
we started on a DBS and there were there
weren't options for us there but it
wasn't necessarily impossible for us to
run it ourselves so we said cool let's
go do it it wasn't really easy either
and you know speaking very frankly it's
basically just the two of us who have
that institutional expertise and we're
not seeing the benefits that we really
well we're not seeing benefits from
having us just run it we're not gave it
like she said we're not giving up
control if we go with you know a managed
offering so that's really where like
keeping up with the pace of kubernetes
really cause like there's features
coming in all the time and like we want
to be able to take advantage of those
features but then it was like you know
we got to do those version
discriminatees version upgrades and
version rollouts and that's just more
burden that we have to take on and just
one additional point to that I think I
was trying to test out sto and it
probably took a week to get it
functioning just right we do have like
kind of a bespoke multi cluster setup so
it took a little more time to you know
like tweak everything to make it work
but um on GK it's a one-click deploy so
that was really cool to find out after
the fact all right and the last question
for me before we throw it open to you
all
tell me about preemptable so preemptable
if you're not aware it's this machine
type that you know isn't guaranteed to
even be available and can kind of be
preempted and reclaimed with like 30
seconds notice but you mentioned in our
prep that you're actually using them so
I'm kind of curious to learn more yeah
for actually all of our non production
environments and our data science
clusters we actually use preemptable x'
for data science it's actually a great
advantage because we're actually
spending cents on the dollar for this
very very beefy machine workloads and
then all of our staging and sandbox
environments are using preemptable x'
and there's actually like a really funny
story like associated with
because pre-emptive bulls are called
preemptable for a reason and we this
happens very rarely but in that in the
two years that we've been you know
running with preemptable in this setup
we actually on a weekend once got a ping
from a developer who was like hey I
don't see any pods in staging is it down
and so you know we all were like oh no
what's going on we like jump in you know
you do keep CC I'll get pods you see
nothing and you're like okay cue CTL get
notes you also see nothing and you're
like okay cool what's going on and then
it turns out that you know there were
none of the instances left to like bid
on for those preemptable x' and so we
just kind of changed the m types and
then it you know staging came back up in
five minutes but that is the risk that
you incur you know doing printables so
don't do that in production for staging
it's fine yeah I think any discussion of
Randall's has to come with that
disclaimer don't don't do it in
production but it's interesting because
you have like non production workloads
that are still kind of very important to
the business like machine learning even
but that just don't necessarily need is
completed by certain times that yeah and
I mean I think especially with those
ones it's important remember that like
as she said you know once we had changed
the instance type you know and and our
nodes were able to come back and
kubernetes was just like oh this state
of the world is not in the desired state
so I need to put it back into desired
state so like with machine learning and
then the training models they were doing
there if the nodes just went away and
then eventually they came back and be
like oh there's still workloads I need
to finish and when it would go and like
make them happen so that was kind of a
like pseudo disaster recovery kind of
scenario yeah I definitely think like
using parentals without communities
would be would be really really hard you
were basically after and you're
basically build communities I think so
anyway cool well with that that's the
end of our prepared content but we looks
like we have about three minutes if you
have any questions and there's also been
a Dory so I believe if there's any Dory
questions we'll have those now as well
but thank you everyone for joining us
today
[Music]